Ángela de momento durante cinco años El
fiscal del distrito de Manhattan ha
estado llevando a cabo una investigación
por lo que decías por ese pago indirecto
a la actriz porno stormy danias de 130
mil dólares a cambio de su silencio por
esas relaciones extramatrimoniales al
parecer
presuntamente lo hizo a través del que
entonces era su abogado personal Michael
bien pues de momento lo que estamos
viendo Es un Jurado investigador un gran
Jurado compuesto por 23 personas que
tienen que decidir si existen motivos
suficientes o no Para que se produzca
esa acusación de hecho una de las cosas
que se ha comentado aquí es que no está
muy claro porque el expresidente apunta
que hoy mismo sería detenido de manera
inminente ya que eso lo tendría que
decidir el propio Jurado con esa
votación que tendrá lugar muy pronto a
partir de allí ya se llevaría en marcha
la acusación durante varias semanas este
Jurado compuesto como digo por 23
miembros ha estado escuchando los
testimonios y ha estado viendo las
pruebas para decidir si realmente hay
motivos suficientes o no para esa
acusación entre los Testigos estarían el
propio Michael cohen y por supuesto la
actriz porno Daniels a esto y Daniel